it's so critical
to recognize your true nature
to be so relentlessly adamant
the truest thing about you that seeking
impulse
for you to know your true nature truly
not to just say
that i have ended seeking
because i know that this is a dream
and that there's nobody here
but for you to have truly built out
the recognition
of the diamond necklace around your neck
the eternal shared awareness
for you to have went through the part of
the bodhisattva going through
buddhahood eradicating the roots of
suffering and misery
and to weave your profound realizations
recognizing yourself as
both a dream delusion
and yet simultaneously a unique creative
contribution to that dream
a unique firework
as bentino massaro says this is like the
absolutes
gps callback infinity has a gps
callback
just like with the heartbeat the
love outward
the dub inward
that's the callback
eternally sending
the observation the awareness
the consciousness out into the dreamed
simulated
realities
just undergo the process of being
intoxicated by maya
by the grand illusion
just to wonder what is my true nature i
can't be a finite biological creature
solely
and to have that turn
from seeking happiness and peace
externally
to turning inward like in the parable of
the prodigal son
and actually undergoing the repetitions
those seeking repetitions just like at
the gym
build up our spiritual mass like
ross says in the law of one
otherwise you just take a concept learn
from neoadvita
that this is all a dream and that the
individual is an illusion
and that this is all just emptiness
happening
and then you still have your ego you
still have anger
you still have suffering and you
catalyze that onto your family
friends community in the world
you haven't actually pierced the veil
there is a veilless veil there is a
gateless gate
it remains for you to recognize it
your true nature and to do
repetitions
to build out more
of the conceptual lattice work that
enables you to recognize the perennial
wisdom
across the mystic traditions
there's so much to learn from
the theravada buddhism meditation
retreat zokchen meditation retreat
reading the daodaching reading the sufi
metaphysics
reading the four books five classics of
confucius
taking entheogens reading the old and
new testament
reading the ten commandments the noble
eightfold path
the anilects
understanding what was meant in greece
by virtue true moral excellence
is that a joke to you
if moral excellence is a joke to you you
have a zero percent chance
of being able to recall your true nature
rapidly
you're gonna get hit with sledgehammers
by the drill sergeant of awakening
which is suffering
there will be a funny meme of people
that say that they've recognized
non-duality and yet also
get extremely angry or frustrated or
jealous
because they've decided that there's no
value
in the buddha hood
of eradicating those roots of suffering
and misery
and therefore they get whapped on the
head with sledgehammers
on a frequent basis by the drill
sergeant of awakening
that is how the mathematics of the
infinite work
that's how the mathematics of source
work
how the energetics of the infinite work
as confucius said in the analysts the
ren
that you have as the greek
said virtue that moral excellence
as you follow the perennial wisdoms in
the noble eightfold path
the ten commandments you recognize more
and more
the similarity across the mystic
traditions why were they saying these
things
why was it so clear that morality
true moral excellence
is what simultaneously fosters
god realization source realization
infinity realization truthfully
truthfully
not just as an intellectual concept but
truthfully embodied in the essence
doing these moral repetitions
and then that catalyzing eudaimonia
as the greek said the maximal human
flourishing possible
you gotta go inward first to go
outward right it's the sure
cause of delight
so as you do those repetitions
higher morality more and more
of a true gnostic being
more and more that god
infinity absolute realized state
is truly known as our nature
and outward effortlessly
like lao tzu said eudaimonia
it's been quite interesting
synthesizing and distilling more
and more of the profound wisdoms and
looking forward to building out
the continued infrastructures to
maximize the efficacy of those
disseminations
as rupert spires says the direct path is
to
peace and happiness that's what we're
talking about
it's the peace it's the happiness it's
to recognizing our true metaphysical
nature
peace and happiness again are not found
externally they're not found in the
illusion of maya they are not found in
the dreamed creation
when you dream at night
and you simulate out a reality and
yourself
as the observer
you as the observer
are not trying to extract happiness and
peace from the simulated environment
you are bringing happiness peace and
witnessing
to the experience of that dreamed
simulated reality
similarly here
when the voyager of the infinite
you or i go out into maya
and we become trapped
by the i am the body
which much of the time does not happen
when you have conscious parents
conscious parents and many of the
indigenous
traditions around the planet they don't
allow
the egoic contracted separate
finite biological creature to
form that bubble
to not know itself truly as infinity as
god as source
so in the ultimate
even the formation of
the egoic contraction is illusory
that's what's meant by non-duality is
infinity never forgets itself
it only appears to forget itself
and that process of appearing
to forget itself is what causes
suffering
misery craving aversion depression
negative emotions attachment to clouds
rather than recognizing oneself as the
sky
and this is why nisargata maharaja was
so adamant about
saying i am not the body
that's this first big step i am not the
body i am not this finite
biological creature i am not that
and that's bold we're talking
somewhere around 90 percent
potentially or more of civilization
believes that they are the body
i am this flesh vehicle
here that is separate from all of the
other
flesh vehicles that is also separate
from the planet that sustains me
and i've birthed and i will die
and this consciousness
is not shared it's not eternal i do not
know
eternity i do not know infinity
i do not know god i do not know source
and i don't care to contemplate that
that is the perversion of maya that is
the intoxication of
maya
and it's beautiful and it's
creative
it's our own labyrinth that we've
architected for ourselves
to undergo the process of
amnesia forgetting and then an amnesia
remembrance so in the ultimate
there is no forgetting and remembrance
that's what non-duality means
but simultaneity
means that there is also the dualistic
concession
which is that there is also
ignorance being intoxicated by maya
forgetting yourself as infinity
and then the process of
janna the process of
mysticism of union yoga
with the absolute with god the turn
inward
recognizing what you truly are
knowledge
so distance yourself immediately
from the i am the body thought distance
yourself
away from being a
finite biological creature
and what do you jump to next you jump to
i am awareness
so you've went from what's very gross
and very
physical and even again quantum
mechanics says that
all is no thing all is energy
that is modulating and appearing as
matter and form
but we'll go ahead and use the
physicalism
example for now where
you are trapped in the thought of i
am this finite biological physical
creature so that's a very gross
very physical very dense
mode of being
i am awareness is a lot more
subtle
what you have to do is you have to
recognize that you are
the sky the awareness the witness
the observer is the sky
and the clouds are
the layers of identity that you've taken
on
you've taken on all of these layers of
your name
your background your profession
your likes your dislikes all of these
thoughts and emotions and beliefs and
perceptions and sensations
those are all clouds and they happen in
the sky
of awareness which is shared
and eternal
now that's a pretty big leap
when you look out recognize
that the
essence of what is doing the looking
is the seer which is what
ramana maharshi calls god
so once you recognize that the seer
itself is awareness
that is god that's a huge step so you're
distancing yourself from the clouds to
the sky
and then next you're recognizing that
the
sky is shared
meaning that awareness is what we share
you and i and all 8 billion of us
share our awareness
that's what the pupil is the pupil is
the unique
shared awareness
that we have
and then the iris that colors
the pupil that
is the creative contribution of infinity
we are
in this dreamed creation
so we've taken ourselves from the i am
the body thought
to what is more subtle which is going
all the way to seeing
itself and becoming
hypersensitive and hyper aware of
seeing itself you have to recognize that
what we're talking about right now is
very elusive
because it's
the distance that we're talking about
is unreal there is no distance
these are the clouds these words
and the blank paper is the sky
there is no distance between
the sky the blankness
and the printing of the
clouds onto the
blank sky this will
last you a couple of seconds
and then it will disappear back to
pure blank empty awareness and then
two seconds later a new modulation
of clouds will appear and this time
it will be art instead of the last time
it was words
so you can't separate the paper
from the artistic modulation
that the paper is experiencing but we
do it so that you can recognize that
you're not the finite
body but rather you're the awareness
you're the eternal
sky the shared sky where all the shared
sky
that has the clouds of maya
of the dreamed creation design appear
in it
so once you get to this point of the
seer
it's you have to really you know work
this out again there's a lot of working
out to do to get to even the point that
you're the seer
so this is the very
unstable neo advaita
just leaps over that process
directly to the absolute and in doing so
the ego never recognizes itself as
a seer it never recognizes that the
awareness is
shared in eternal and in never doing
those repetitions
it never even leaves the ego state
it just carries concepts with it
there's a reason why it's a gym
there's a reason why it's a path there's
a reason why
there's thousands of years of mystic
traditions that have been teaching these
things
and there's a reason why there's a
perennial wisdom across them which
points to the same one end
all of these different paths
simultaneity is key because infinity
is both already
whole and yet it is also on a journey
you are the unique voyager
of that infinitude
that is expressing itself in this dream
you are a unique firework that's why you
have a unique iris that's why even
genetically
dna biologically were 99.9 percent
similar between humans and 0.1 percent
different
you have a unique contributory gift to
bring
to this dream civilization
and this is also the
important recognition for non-duality
to bring in is that although the
individual
is a dream delusion it is also a unique
expression of infinity and so the west
is not wrong
actually we need a synthesis between the
west and the east
because the individuation is the
mathematics of the infinite
diversity in oneness is the mathematics
of the infinite sri aurobindo and the
mother mira alfossa
taught
although the diversity is illusory and
dreamed
the diversity is also the way that
infinity expresses itself
as unique fireworks and that's what is
meant by
self actualization god actualization
infinity actualization is the artistic
expression outward
which can only be done from the absolute
highest morality
once one has rendered as raman maharshi
said the most important service
that you can bring to humanity which is
your god realization your infinity
realization
so you already are source yet it remains
for you to recognize it
and it also remains for you to undergo
the buddhahood
process of eradicating your suffering
and the suffering
of your family friends community world
and it also remains for you to optimize
your science entrepreneurship polymothy
creativity
digital quotient in the outward
expression as well
so be careful around some of the neo
advaita
around there is nobody here
there's nothing to seek it's already
whole
and then to be stuck in egoic
anger carrying around
this concept
so the i am awareness state is much more
subtle and you recognize that the
awareness is shared
and then you also recognize it's eternal
so this is just
one creation design so now you're really
far away from the i am the body thought
i am the body is
so old news to you
because now you've recognized even
eternity
you are that you are the eternity i
and my father are one tatwa
so i'm not the body i am the father i
am god i am source i am
infinity
this is but one expression one creation
design
one dream that we're experiencing
which is really fun and playful
this is lila the divine play but
know thyself as was written on the top
of the temple of apollo at delphi two
thousand five hundred years ago
the delphic maxim know thyself
know yourself as infinity as eternal and
so then the i am the body
really dissolves and again these are
those repetitions
this is what's meant by the absolute gps
callback
this is what's meant by seeking is the
truest thing about you
these are the repetitions in the gym so
that
i am the body completely dissolves
truly and not just saying
that ah it's all just a dream
ah there's nobody here there's no path
no problem perfect
now i get to just be
you're declining the truest thing about
you which is the seeking impulse
if you do that you're declining
the absolute gps callback
and you will be hit with sledgehammers
because you'll freak out egoically
and you'll get hit with a sledgehammer
and then you'll be like oh my gosh wow
why did i stop seeking
how do i not freak out egoically like
that
that's what will happen
so now we're at the i am
infinity stage
the i am infinity stage
is the absolute realization you're not
even the agent anymore
you're not even awareness anymore
you are infinity
you're beyond being everything and
you're beyond
being nothing
you're just infinity
cool
to recognize oneself as infinity
one can leverage
really good visualizations like we've
been communicating in our previous
videos
where you can see things like
even this can be viewed
as all of the different creation designs
that are happening like in the benoit
mandelbrot infinite fractal zoom
and this little guy right here
the one that has that unique little
mark on it that is this
creation design this is but one
of all of these creation designs that
have all
of these different styles of math and
physics
and vehicles
that infinity
chooses to be the observer the witness
the awareness
through
and so the goal then in the i am
infinity realization
is to recognize yourself at that scale
it's no longer i am the body
it's not even i am awareness which is
just
your own awareness which is great but
just your own
which is great much better to be the sky
than the clouds
right and then to recognize that the
awareness is shared among us all
and its eternal that's a massive next
step
and then to get yourself even to the i
am infinity realization
which is recognizing that all
all of the
creation designs all of the dreams
that are being birthed and dying
at the rate of the hummingbirds
wings that are flapping like in that
mandelbrot infinite fractal zoom
that infinity is that and you
are that so you are
infinity expressing itself like that
you are all of what infinity is and what
it's expressing
and you're beyond all of that you're
beyond the nothingness you're beyond the
void you're beyond the shunya
you're beyond even that formlessness
you're beyond even that you're beyond
metaphysical zero
and you're beyond all that is both
and that's taking this last thorn of
even
saying that i'm the agent of infinity
i'm the agent of infinity that's
experiencing these creation designs
and even plucking out that last thorn
like bentino massaro says and
recognizing
yourself as completely agentless
no attributes no agent
total beyond this beyond everything
beyond nothing
so it takes a little bit of time to go
from the i am the body
to the i am awareness to the i am
infinity
and practicing the repetitions on a
daily basis
to get ourselves closer and closer to
the i am
infinity realization and distancing
ourselves
more and more from the lie from the
ignorance
from the maya that is i am the body
that is not your true nature and the
truest thing about you is the seeking
impulse
that is trying to wake you up and get
you to realize
your true nature
do you want to actually
truly know thyself
or do you just want to say that there's
nothing for me to do
or do you just want to hear content like
this
and then not undergo the process
of diving deeper into all of these
profound aphorisms
and books and retreats and entheogens
so many people are so scared they don't
want to
lose their layers of identity their ego
they're so worried
i've spent my entire life building up
these layers
of identity and ego and you tell me to
even
micro dose on magic mushrooms this
intelligence that is billions of years
old
yeah bro a billion year intelligence is
going to give you some
profound insights you will be
flooded with novel
neural modulation that will dissolve
your egoic
default mode network enable and enhance
not only oneness true knowledge of
yourself but also
maximize your creativity
creating new connections across neural
networks that previously weren't talking
before
so it's really important that science
continues doing
its thing as well and we synthesize the
novel realizations
in neuroscience and entheogens with the
perennial
wisdoms in spirituality
this is key this is
the truest thing about you is
recognizing
that
i am infinity wanting to know myself
so i can't be the body okay
i'm the awareness i'm the scott the sky
in which the experiences of the dream
creation design are happening
and that sky is shared and it's eternal
wow huge step okay
i want to know myself even more i am
infinity
i am the actual infinitude
that is birthing all of these creation
designs and
experiencing them eternally
exploring endlessly
in lila in the divine play i am
that we are that
that is who we are
beyond everything and beyond
nothing beyond all attributes beyond
all agent
true simultaneity will tell you that you
are
that changeless metaphysical zero
and you are simultaneously
this i am infinitude
expressing itself creatively endlessly
across all these creation designs
you're the eternal shared awareness
experiencing those
and you're also this unique creative
expression of it
and even some people are trapped
in the i am the body thoughts
and that that is still infinity
expressing itself
it's veiled from its own nature right
now
infinity knows itself the creature
that thinks that it's separate has this
gps callback from that infinitude
pierce this veilus veil wake up to your
true nature here's a little feather
here's a little rock don't make me bring
the sledgehammer out
because the drill sergeant of awakening
suffering
that's what wakes it up to its true
nature
so
if you have friends
that are stuck in the i am the body
thought
do really simple exercises with them
bring these child-like analogies to them
the very simple ones like rupert spire
shared with us
these are the clouds
this is the sky the pure bear empty
awareness that is shared and eternal
forever modulated by
clouds experience
and gently help them gracefully wisely
help them be a vortex
that's what the tantric path is sahaja
samadhi the middle way
weave your realizations into the social
fabric
maximize human potential
foster steward the enlightened
civilization
in this beautiful dream that we share
and do the repetitions
the light bulb will stop flickering and
it will stay on permanently
truly not just as a concept while
bathing an ego
but it will truly stay on as eternal
shared awareness and then it will also
truly stay on as the recognition of i
am infinity i am everything i am nothing
and i am beyond
and again there's plenty of good books
plenty of good aphorisms
start with the absolute greatest
that i've ever written
there's the doubt of ching is incredible
the four books five classics are great
the old and new testament are fantastic
the poetry of rumi is very good
dabble into entheogens as well microdose
again that billionaire intelligence of
magic mushrooms
put aphorisms up on your walls i and my
father are one tatvam asi
put these aphorisms up on your walls
luke 17 21 the kingdom of god is within
you
really dig into the parable of the
prodigal son
attend theravada buddhism meditation
retreat 10 days complete
silence no eye contact no talking no
technology
just the most direct conservative
teachings of the buddha
eradicate suffering at the root level
attend zocchen
as well find that rigpa that very ground
that we speak of that very metaphysical
zero
the very unmanifested
that very shunya that very voidness
know thyself
and express thyself
from that absolute highest effortlessly
as a unique creative expression
unique creative firework in this dream
creation design
and that's those those are the
repetitions
and on that outward expression there's
all the repetitions and polymathy
gaining the core concepts from the
planetary disciplines of science and
engineering
of art of entrepreneurship
having high digital and emotional
intelligence and weaving
all of the core concepts from the
disciplines into a latticework that you
can then
use to maximize that artistic expression
someone that's very deeply god realized
and spiritual when it's coupled together
with a deep profound understanding of
tokenomics and smart contracts
cryptocurrency and decentralization
it enables them to be an architect of
the future protocols that enable
a shared equity
stakeholding in the growing pie
of our future
so to be able to span both sides of that
god realization as well as the science
engineering entrepreneurship art digital
quotient emotional quotient
all that type of stuff it's critical
it's critical that's what polymathy
truly is
polymathy is the enlightened state plus
the empowered state
the self-realization plus the
self-actualization
like the video if it brought you value
subscribe to the channel if you haven't
already would love to hear your thoughts
in the comments
thank you so much for commenting on the
videos
i love reading them
i love seeing where you're at in your
journeys it's exciting for me
i'm really grateful for you for you
checking out the content
and glad that it does resonate
and share it with other people that it
will resonate with
you can join the channel below as well
and gain exclusive perks and
also be able to help us
actualize all of our creative projects
that we have going on which is super
exciting
and
just like to make a shout out to andy
bittner from
guaranteed clean energy
they're doing incredible work
transitioning
schools and municipalities over from the
old archaic
energy architectures to the new modern
sustainable clean ones
and he's been a
very gracious patron of what we're doing
and we're really grateful to him
and this is sort of
the style of
future that we ask from
the 2 200 billionaires on the planet to
225 000 ultra high net worth individuals
and families
contribute to artists contribute to
entrepreneurs contribute to scientists
engineers god realized spiritual leaders
contribute to them help them actualize
their biggest goals
that's how to maximize planetary
prosperity and also
for those god realized spiritual leaders
to take their
clean mirrors of infinity and bring them
to
the egoic levels of consciousness that
are in the greatest positions of
leadership
around our world and help refine them
away from ego
as their satguru
so
that's all adore you thank you so much
re-baseline repetitions
i am not the body i am awareness
shared eternal
i am infinity
i am that
beyond everything and nothing
you